at any rate one of these scientists that
I was listening to several years ago
also happened to be a Jewish rabbi and
in his talk he said you know you
Christians never really understood the
meaning of the third commandment to not
take the name of the LORD thy God in
vain he said for some reason you thought
that that meant you were not supposed to
say god damn you
well it isn't very nice to say god damn
you but do you know that's not even
close to the meaning of the commandment
vaana's is emptiness to speak something
in vain is to speak it with emptiness
with futility it's a waste of time
he said the meaning of the commandment
as it was understood for centuries in
Judaism was don't even speak the name
don't ever in your lifetime pronounce
the sacred name Yahweh never and he said
this gave us at the very beginnings of
the judeo-christian tradition a cosmic
humility about God that once you think
you've got God in your pocket that you
understand the great mystery religion
always becomes he said arrogant and
idolatrous where we love our
explanations of God more than actually
falling in love with God where God
refuses to ever be an object of the
intellect but is only known by those who
enter into love and surrender secondly
he said and probably a lot of you know
this that when you write Hebrew you
actually just write the consonants and
what it means to be an educated Jew is
to have memorized the appropriate vowels
and to know how to fill in the
appropriate vowels and the appropriate
places
I knew that from my short Hebrew class
but the third part is what I most want
to leave with you tonight
he said did you know that the consonants
used in the spelling of the sacred name
Yahweh are in fact the only consonants
that if correctly pronounced do not
allow you to use your tongue or close
your lips in fact we know that the
pronouncing of the sacred name was an
attempt to imitate and replicate breath
that it was inhalation and exhalation
and then he began to do it into the
microphone and in a few minutes
tears started being audible in the room
in a room of PhDs I now give this to
every crowd I can because it can change
your life